cheating
um thank you for being here thank you
for having me so much you are so
talented thank you you do everything
thank you yeah I'm very excited that you
have to be busy I know me too yeah too
so tomorrow's Valentine's Day so I'm
usually pretty low-key what do you do
you like to go big on Valentine's Day or
do you like to keep it small
it depends completely on what I'm doing
sometimes I do like a galentine's day
I'll probably be spending it at home
with my dogs and my girlfriend thank you
yeah that sounds good um if you did like
have a big down stay Valentine's Day
plan like um like a big date is there a
particular song that's like your Vibe
like your that's an amazing song it's
like a baby making song oh yeah please
is that what you want I don't want to
make anymore no no but I like a baby
making song it's a great song If anyone
in the audience it's um it's a huge it's
not you find it on YouTube she's called
akua Nuru
it's called poetry how does it make you
feel listen to it babies will be made
babies will be name them Cara if I am
right yeah name them Cara I will not I
will be skipping that song just in case
um so what about a favorite like breakup
do you do you go to like any artist or a
song like if you're having like an
emotional time yeah Alanis Morissette
you ought to know oh come on how do you
I don't think a song is beat that one no
my friends called me Janice because it's
my Alter Ego I just kind of like yeah
scream it yeah yeah well if you don't
then there's something wrong with it
yeah that's what the song is for yeah
it's the best yeah she gave us a vessel
and we're using it using it yes
[Music]
[Applause]